the opening scene begins with a
corporate middle manager named Joe who
wakes up inside a prison-like structure
he's got no idea where he is or how he
got there he gets up and searches for
his phone in his pockets but it's
missing he looks around to see the
Towering walls a securely locked heavy
metal door and a huge Stone Mill at the
center perplexed Joe begins yelling for
help prompting a neighboring cellmate to
ask him to shut up Joe approaches a
small air vent and requests the man help
him understand what's going on the
latter tells him that Joe was dosed and
for a few days he's going to feel very
depressed because of the side effects
and afterwards he'll still feel
depressed because he's trapped he also
suggests that Joe takes some rest as
tomorrow is going to be a long day for
him while Joe tries to wrap his head
around this new reality one of the
guards drops some basic food and a water
bottle through a door slot seeing this
Joe immediately rushes towards it and
pleads with the guard to let him go
explaining that he has a pregnant wife
to take care of however the guard
disregards his pleas and closes the slot
abruptly hurting Joe's hand after this
Joe walks back bandages his hand with
his tie and proceeds to eat the provided
food later in the evening a light
appears on the wall and an AI Voice Hi
mystery recapped here welcomes Joe to
something referred to as Advanced Career
Training completely befuddled by the
ongoing situation Joe again turns to his
neighboring cellmate for more
information this time the man explains
that this prison-like setting is a part
of malard the company where Joe is
employed according to the man numerous
employees just like Joe have ended up in
this place due to their degrading
performance at work huh I wonder if this
is all a metaphor says Joe Early in the
Morning Joe receives another round of
food along with instructions from the
guard to dispose of waste through a
toilet hole a while later Joe makes a
startling Discovery when he notices
something bare buried in the ground a
human skull alarmed he rushes to the
vent and inquires about any deaths
occurring in this place the cellmate
then confirms that many employees have
indeed died while working here Joe
wonders how any company could operate in
such a way that's cute Joe lives under a
rock in response the man explains that
they all signed a contract before
joining Mard in which they've
voluntarily agreed for all of this they
never said anything because nobody has
time to read all the stipulations
mentioned in a contract shortly after
the AI voice addresses Joe briefing him
about his new job today I am going to
explain a form of torture called the
voice says that Joe will be working from
6:00 a.m. to 10 p.m. and his work
involves pushing the Stone Mill each
Revolution would earn him a point he
must achieve a daily quot of 50
revolutions or else he'll be punished
furthermore the employee with the lowest
point score will be terminated
regardless of whether they meet their
quota or not Joe desperately pleads with
the AI voice to let him go home but the
cellmate tells him that it's useless as
the company will keep them as long as
they need with no alternative Joe begins
his laborious work it isn't easy to
secure the revolutions as it requires a
lot of strength nevertheless Joe
dedicates his utmost effort and manages
to accomplish 100 revolutions by Days
End tired he goes to sleep only to be
awakened by the anguished cry eyes of a
fellow employee who is going to be
killed the next morning Joe is having
his breakfast while talking to his
neighboring cellmate he wonders what's
the point of the quota because the
employees are terminated even if they
meet their target the neighbor replies
that good enough isn't good enough for
Mard as they Converse the neighbor
learns that Joe made 100 revolutions
yesterday and he advises him not to push
himself too hard or else Mard will
expect more however Joe believes that
working hard will be his ticket to
freedom and a return to his pregnant
wife later while working Joe recalls the
day when he presented his wife Kate with
their new house she was worried as it
was an expensive place given to him by
his company but he somehow comforted her
maybe it was with the freaking house the
next day Kate reminded him of the
doctor's appointment and asked him to
take a day off but Joe hesitated causing
her distress she was unhappy with his
prioritization of work over family jeez
lady he just gave you a house 24 hours
ago when the alarm rang Joe snaps out to
the present and realizes that he's done
150 revolutions following his work shift
the guard summons Joe to the door and
instructs him to undress himself now
that you're all swole for us why don't
you get naked thinking that he's about
to be eliminated Joe points out his
achievement of 150 revolutions but the
guard doesn't listen the door opens and
Joe is escorted to a dimly lit area
where he is dowed with water to his
relief this unexpected ordeal is simply
a bath day pass and Joe continues to
work harder and harder under the
Relentless Sun the sweltering heat
causes him to drink more water because
of which he empties his bottle desperate
he attempts to Signal the guard for more
water but his neighbor informs him that
they only give them enough food and
water to keep them alive the neighbor
also provides him with an idea to quench
his thirst he needs to urinate in the
bottles filter it using the insoles of
his shoes and hide it behind the pillar
as stock however Joe feels disgusted and
refuses to do do so he continues to work
despite his exhaustion only thinking of
Kate in the process he recounts how she
was worried about the medical bills and
how he assured her to work harder when
the day comes to an end fatigue
overtakes him and the AI voice offers
congratulations for his remarkable
achievement revealing that he has
accomplished
370 revolutions while resting Joe spots
the name Alex carved beneath the wooden
handle and inquires about it to his
neighbor the latter reveals that Alex is
the only only person who managed to get
out of this place just then Mard rewards
Joe with an engraved pen for his day's
work however since it's of no use to him
he becomes angry and throws an outburst
the next day as work begins Joe notices
that his daily quota has been increased
to 370 revolutions he claims that he
cannot meet this target showing his
injured hands is evidence however the AI
voice contends that humans are more
capable than they think just do the damn
work watch out out and take care
following this Joe begins working only
to discover that it doesn't give him a
point despite completing a revolution
instead his clock Bears an x mark when
asked the neighbor clarifies that Joe
has been penalized and must now achieve
two revolutions to earn a point which
means his new quota is 740 left with no
choice Joe begins his labor he pushes
himself to the limits but fatigue
eventually overcomes him and he gives up
at the end of the day the the AI voice
informs him that he has failed to meet
his quota and believes that he might
need a new motivation then Kate's
profile appears on the screen and the AI
voice threatens to bring her to this
place as well this freaks Joe out so he
hastily promises to meet his Target
tomorrow the AI offers him a chance to
prove his commitment please like And
subscribe on the next day Joe covers the
mill handle with his coat to reduce the
strain on his injured hand he then puts
in all of his strength to SEC cure the
revolutions at one point his exhaustion
leads to hallucinations in which he sees
a mocking version of himself ridiculing
his faith in malard nevertheless Joe
manages to ignore these distractions and
persists in his work meeting the quota
just moments before the clock strikes 10
the penalty is finally lifted from his
record and Joe drifts off to sleep
beside the mill in the early hours of
the morning he is awakened by the AI
voice which presents him with a short
video of his wife in the hospital with
their their newborn child overwhelmed by
A Rush of emotions Joe cries realizing
that he has become a father but he
couldn't be there later on he approaches
the air vent and asks the neighbor about
the details on how Alex got out of this
hell the neighbor is hesitant at first
but when he hears about Joe's newly born
baby he relates it with his own life
story and decides to help him he then
tells Joe to check the spot behind a
pillar where the CCTV camera can't reach
following his instruction Joe checks the
wall only to discover a circular area
realizing that it's a weak spot he grabs
his engraved pen and starts digging at
the wall the days pass by and Joe Spends
His free time digging the hole in the
wall eventually he makes it big enough
for him to crawl through venturing into
it he ends up in a dark area Joe looks
around in hopes of finding a way out but
his efforts prove futile when the guard
finds him and incapacitates him when Joe
regains Consciousness he finds that the
hole has been filled again as a
punishment his quote is increased to
1,000 revolutions while the neighbor
gets his leg chopped off feeling
helpless Joe apologizes to his neighbor
but the latter is in so much pain that
he won't be able to work anymore Joe
wonders if he can do anything but the
neighbor reveals that the entire place
is controlled by algorithms and they
can't reason with AI all that matters is
the views he also discloses that he was
the one who created the algorithm as he
used to work in the IT department upon
hearing this Joe has the realization if
they all stop working and make no points
it'll be a tie and the algorithm can
punish nobody Fired Up by this idea Joe
tries to form a union with his fellow
inmates and convince them not to work ah
the analogy deepens soon after the
working hour begins but no one works as
they all appear to be persuaded by Joe
but when the work time is about to end
the AI voice announces that the
employees with zero points will be
terminated fearing death the cellmates
start working which causes Joe's plan to
fail the neighbor then urges Joe to
rotate the mill and not to worry about
him left with no choice Joe secures a
revolution earning him a point just
before the time runs out however Joe
feels very bad for the neighbor who
didn't make any points due to the injury
Joe is 100% responsible for that man's
death that night the neighbor who knows
that he'll die soon makes a confession
he is in fact Alex he tried to escape
through the tunnel but was captured by
the guard much like Joe and placed in a
separate cell he chose not to disclose
this information to Joe hoping that a
second escape attempt would be different
I take back what I said this is all that
guy's fault after a brief conversation
they bid each other farewell as Joe
settles down to sleep he's disturbed by
the anguished cries of Alex before being
eliminated the next day the AI presents
Joe with another video featuring his
wife and their now walking son realizing
the time he has lost in this cell he
becomes infuriated and vents his anger
at the company he insults malard for
taking everything from him despite his
10 years of loyal service unfortunately
the AI deems his behavior unacceptable
and orders an immediate execution
following this a group of Mard employees
walk in along with the guard while
preparing a lethal injection the guard
passes some mean remarks regarding his
wife and his son this enrages Joe who
then attacks him and starts punching him
brutally the AI then announces that the
guard failed his task and that if Joe
completes the guard's termination he
will be promoted to the next level
hearing this Joe stops and screams that
he is not a monster he also claims that
he won't let the company make him into a
monster so he quits right then Joe
regains his Consciousness and is shocked
to find himself back in his office it
turns out that it's just an advanced
virtual simulation with employees
connected to a machine through
head-mounted devices shortly after an H
Shar Personnel bearing a resemblance to
the guard approaches Joe and reveals
that although he felt that months have
passed it has only been an hour in
reality it means that Joe's son hasn't
been born yet and everything is as it
was the man further discloses that Joe's
inability to secure a promotion was not
due to a lack of competence but because
he hadn't been adequately challenged to
do better they challenged him in the
virtual world and his performance
excelled way more than they expected as
a result they finally decided to promote
Joe to the next level in the aftermath
the HR representative escorts Joe to his
new office cabin acquainting him with
his new targets and productivity
expectations he also has Joe sign a
non-disclosure agreement stipulating
that he cannot share any details about
his experience with anyone once the man
departs Joe contacts his wife and his
eyes well up upon hearing her voice he
expresses his love for her and his
unborn child before hanging up the call
the movie ends with Joe vowing to burn
down the entire malard company jeez
really okay cool subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching